let's start with what matters most as
usual and it's america's energy crisis
now from sticker shock at the gas pump
to extra dollars spent hitting your home
americans are feeling the pinch triple
a's average has the cost of a gallon of
gas rising over a dollar compared to
2021 more expensive gas drives inflation
because higher inflation costs are
passed down to the customers making your
milk your eggs everything else more
costly probably don't need me to tell
you that and for those living in frigid
parts of the u.s more expensive natural
gas bringing the heat to both your home
and your wallet
now abroad with russia and ukraine on
the brink of war already soaring energy
prices run the risk of skyrocketing even
further how about a hundred dollars a
barrel why because america is once again
dependent on other nations for oil
former energy secretary uh under
president trump rick perry joins me in a
matter of moments to offer some
solutions but first here's a quick
history lesson on how we got here
in 1908 the advent of the model t
revolutionary this put the world on
wheels with the need for fossil fuel oil
and refined gas to power the first
affordable automobile oil would become a
global commodity black liquid gold
jumping to the 60s early 70s gas prices
were below 50 cents but that would take
a drastic turn
fast forward to 1973 opec put an oil
embargo in place crippling the petroleum
supply forcing gas prices to surge
[Music]
it was to punish the u.s and other
nations for supporting israel after
egypt and syria launched a surprise
attack on the holy land
three months later oil prices more than
quadrupled the first oil crisis hit odd
even rationing was introduced drivers
with even numbers on their license
plates could only get gas on
even-numbered days likewise for odd
number plates the era of cheap energy
came to an end
1974 the focus becoming energy
independent that mission was born that
came under president richard nixon for
decades republican and democratic
president said the only way to achieve
energy independence was through strict
conservation measures alternate forms of
energy
flash forward to donald trump's
presidency he didn't think another
energy plan was the answer the
government needed to just get out of the
way so oil companies could do their job
in 2018 the us exported more in oil than
we imported for the first time in
decades
thanks to trump lifting drilling
restrictions on energy production and
going full speed on fossil fuel
production including fracking which is
extracting gas and oil from rock that's
deep underground we are energy
independent for the first time under
president trump the u.s monthly crude
oil production peaked in 2019 at 12.3
million barrels per day by november 2021
that dropped to around 11.2 million
president biden's administration made us
dependent again biden killed pipelines
reversed nearly all of trump's
pro-drilling policies making the west
and northern europe depended on russia
for reliable energy
now a war between ukraine and russia
could raise the stakes worldwide
president biden vows to target russia's
energy industry suspending its nordstrom
2 natural gas pipeline that runs through
germany while they try to make russia
suffer so would their customers like the
nato countries if we kept our past plans
in place we could have been our allies
supplier cutting off natural gas could
have ripple effects in oil markets i
spoke to the governor of north dakota he
is being forced by the biden
administration to keep 500 000 barrels
of oil a day
in the ground if those 500 000 barrels
of oil day were allowed to be produced
it would help the price on gas and we
wouldn't have joe biden begging opec to
increase
at a time when we are trying to get oil
to european partners president biden
says pump less dig less you're paying
more because the administration is
restricting more gas prices in the u.s
are up 40 percent a year but unlike the
1970s this is the price the president
chose to pay
so
unbelievable right i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now